comment les choses elle arrive dans la
vie comment il faut le voir pour le
croire
ce jour là dont je vous parle il devait
être exactement 11h30 11h45 à peu près
et il y avait un monde fou au café chez
pépettes au bar palace à bab el oued en
pleine avenue de la bouse arias comme
c'est la vérité c'est pas c'est pas le
café chez bell vous avez dû connaître et
chacun c'était l'heure de l'apéritif
chacun paie sa tournée la chaîne la
mienne la tienne la mienne la tienne la
mienne y en avait que c'est eric la
sienne la sienne la sienne parce que
vous avez des oursins dans la poche et à
cette heure ci qui on voit rentrer à
cette heure-ci qui on voit rentré au
café
car oui ton lui-même capitaux en
personne il se pointe devant le comptoir
et comme si vous venez d'être nommé
ministre de la culture et des beaux-arts
il demande au patron aphatie lui dit je
voudrais un café bien chaud bien servi
bien sucré et se prépare ne quand le
patron bombe au grill été amusé lui sert
son café il se dit il avait l'habitude
des barjots des moitiés food et demi fou
défaut entier il avait c'était parce
qu'ils banque helaba
il a dix pour cent cinquante francs je
vais perdre mon temps avec ce sens
montre là c'est pas la peine bon j'ai eu
du cher son café puis ça fait rien va
nous faire son café ça t'a rien le
lendemain quand we touch se repointe à
la même heure et avec plus de culot que
la veille il demande au patron je
voudrais un café bien chaud bien servi
bien sucré et je paye pas le patron bon
bougre pépettes réussir son café il
avait d'autres choses à faire c'était
l'heure du coup de feu avec le kenya est
tout bon ça va
le surlendemain même chanson mr mêmes
paroles ça commençait à devenir un tube
d'ailleurs c'était maracana
exactement et semer et se met quoi
maintenant à la scala de milan il jappe
répète je voudrais un café bien chaud
bien servi bien sucré il se prépare et
le manège comme ça ils durent pendant le
dise ou dix jours dix jours dix jours le
11e jour les pattes ils en avaient marre
il appelle un copain lui qui ne l'ont
pas une armoire à glace faut dire que
vous dire que ceux qui ne l'ont pas la
grâce à dieu c'était vraiment quand on
voulait avoir de londres et qui avait du
soleil on se met à côté pub c'était un
parasol à lui tout entier c'est un
parasol bon il lui dit écoute écoute
chinaud fais moi plaisir celui là qui
vient tous les jours
il commence non seulement il m'a pourri
la vie mais ils commencent hamas fixiez
et il m'a pompé l'air alors j'en peux
plus je suis comme ça je vais tomber
s'il vient demain tu vas te le prendre
tu vas t'occuper de lui et tu vas te
jeter comme une bouteille non consignés
en douceur
tu vas me jeter parce que j'en peux plus
de lui j'en peux plus encore plus mais
tu le fais tranquillement le 11e jour
toronto il se pointe comme s'ils avaient
une carte orange d'abonnement il se
pointe
ils se pointent et demande
je voudrais un café bien chaud bien
sucré bien servi je sais pas si l'on
s'approche de luz y côtoie vient vers
toi toi bien
dis moi ça fait dix jours que tu viens
comme ça tu demandes un café bien chaud
bien sucré comme si tu étais toi le
directeur de la plantation de café dis
moi tu n'as pas peur toi tu n'as pas
peur campbellton il regarde et lui dire
moi j'ai pas peur moi et toi qui as peur
tu toi sinon il se met à claquer de rire
et on pouvait plus diriger moi j'ai pas
peur avant on ne tient pas peur toi et
quand et où se tourner vers le comptoir
est dit alors pour nous deux de café
bien chaud bien sucré bien servi et
rompait pas